So, here we are back with our broken formality test.
And what I have done is I've changed the input a little bit so let's run these new inputs.
And what we can see is the function has not made a couple of mistakes.
For example, it is indicated that 9 is prime, and it is indicated that 25 is prime
or of course neither of those numbers is prime.
So, let's go back to the code and look the mistake. The algorithm here is generally a valid one.
It's fine to first of all special case the even numbers,
and it's fine then to loop between 3 and the square root of the number.
So, the problem is that Python's range function
does not loop through 3 and the square of the input number
rather it loops between 3 and 1 less than the square of the input number.
So, we can fix this, of course, easily by adding 1 to the square root
causing it to actually test against the full range that it needs to test
in order to have a successful formality test.
So, let us run this code and see what happens.
So, 6 is not prime, 7 is. None of the rest of these numbers are prime except for 29.
So, the question is what happened here? Why did test coverage fail to identify the bug?
And the answer is sort of simple--statement coverage is a rather crude metric
that only checks whether each statement executes once.
Each statement executes at least once that let's a lot of bugs slip through.
For example, we can have a statement execute, but it computes the wrong numerical answer
or what happened here a loop executed,
but it executed for the wrong number of times computing the wrong result.
The lesson here is we should not let complete coverage plus a number of successful test cases
fool as into thinking that a piece of code of right.
It's often the case that deeper analysis is necessary.